Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Buongiorno a tutti,
appunto sono Lorenzo Cantini e ho 22 anni.
Scusate l'emozione.
(Applausi)
Io sono qui e vorrei raccontarvi
la storia di una persona
che ha deciso di crearsi un'opportunità,
un'opportunità lavorativa;
ma soprattutto una persona che ha creduto
e ha dato alla voglia di fare,
non soltanto mia
ma di tutte le persone
che mi hanno dato una mano,
dei miei colleghi
e anche della mia famiglia.
Infatti io sono il cofondatore,
insieme a mio fratello,
di una startup di Firenze
che realizza e progetta
stampanti tridimensionali
a basso costo ed open source.
Prima cosa, che cos'è
una stampante tridimensionale,
e come funziona.
Una stampante 3D
è una macchina in grado
di materializzare un oggetto.
Infatti si parte da un disegno 3D
che può essere reperito su internet
o può essere disegnato
tramite un programma CAD;
e poi, tramite un software
presente nel computer,
lo si converte in un linguaggio
che poi verrà elaborato
dalla macchina stessa.
E la macchina, sciogliendo
un filo di plastica,
lo deposita strato su strato
fino a realizzare un oggetto.
Forse un po' di magia
c'è anche in questa tecnologia qua.
Ma per spiegare ancora meglio
come funziona una stampante
tridimensionale,
provate ad immaginare di avere
nelle proprie mani un ananas,
di dividerlo a fette
e poi a ricostruirlo
mettendo una fetta sopra un'altra fetta;
ed è così che funziona
una stampante tridimensionale.
Ma quello che noi oggi facciamo
non sarebbe stato possibile
senza questo progetto,
che è il progetto Rep Rap,
che è un progetto open source,
nato in Inghilterra,
che aveva come finalità la divulgazione
delle conoscenze necessarie
per la realizzazione, appunto,
di una stampante tridimensionale
a basso costo ed open source.
Questo progetto è stato ideato
da questo signore qua,
il professore dell'università
di Bath Adrian Bowyer,
il quale ipotizzò una macchina
in continua evoluzione,
nel senso in grado di evolversi, crescere;
ma soprattutto,
anche in grado di replicare
alcune delle componenti che la formavano.
Infatti, le stampanti 3D
che noi produciamo
hanno parti plastiche che vengono prodotte
da altre stampanti 3D:
macchine che creano altre macchine.
Un po' alla Terminator,
se vogliamo vederla in questo modo.
Ma il progetto Rep Rap,
appunto, come ho detto all'inizio,
è ancora un progetto open source
e questo gli ha permesso, in pochi anni,
di divulgarsi, di svilupparsi,
di arricchirsi,
tant'è che noi stessi abbiamo dato
un nostro contributo a questo progetto,
sviluppando un nostro modello
di stampante tridimensionale,
che abbiamo nominato,
in onore di uno scienziato
omonimo toscano, "Galileo".
Vengo da Firenze!
(Applausi)
Ma torniamo alla foto di famiglia.
Appunto, alcuni dei membri
che formano Kentstrapper
sono proprio dei miei familiari;
e secondo me c'è un aspetto
molto importante
in questa foto, in questo contesto,
ovvero tre generazioni di artigiani
che lavorano insieme per creare qualcosa
che è a metà tra il replicator
di Star Trek e un prodotto artigianale,
perché beh -
e lo dico con molta gioia
e con molta enfasi -
ogni nostra stampante
viene prodotta artigianalmente:
siamo noi che tagliamo i pezzi,
li puliamo, li assembliamo,
insomma, è un prodotto
artigianale al 100%.
Questo è il modo in cui abbiamo
lavorato finora,
con mio fratello che si occupa
delle componenti elettroniche -
in fin dei conti,
è l'unico ingegnere elettronico
che attualmente abbiamo -
poi c'è mio padre che si occupa
delle parti meccaniche;
e c'è pure anche
nostro cugino, cugina e zio
che ci danno una mano
nell'assemblaggio delle stampanti.
Ma non è finita qua.
Abbiamo coinvolto pure nostro nonno,
che con tanto di mascherina
si occupa di rifinire
le parti plastiche
che compongono le stampanti.
Nostro nonno ha 77 anni,
aggiungerei "suonati"
ed è sempre stato un artigiano.
Secondo me è straordinario
pensare al fatto
che quando nostro nonno ha iniziato
a lavorare da artigiano, a Firenze,
molto probabilmente vi erano ancora
delle botteghe artigiane;
e oggi, a quella
che viene definita, da molti,
"L'alba della Terza
Rivoluzione Industriale",
i suoi nipoti stanno
anch'essi lavorando da artigiani,
o meglio da artigiani tecnologici,
in una parola "makers".
Ma qualche tempo fa,
è successo qualcosa di interessante.
All'auto di nostro nonno
si era rotta una componente,
questo gancetto che vedete,
che teneva unita
la cappelliera al portabagagli.
Si tratta di un pezzo insignificante,
se voi avete presente
tutte le componenti
che forma un'automobile;
o meglio, insignificante
fin quando non si rompe,
perché non so quanti di voi
sarebbero in grado di dire
dove poter reperire
questo pezzo di ricambio;
e noi, dopo alcune ricerche,
ancora non siamo in grado di dirlo.
Quindi, secondo me,
il discorso è tutt'altro che banale
e potremmo riassumerlo in una domanda:
che cosa succede,
quando le cose si rompono?
Beh, secondo la nostra esperienza
possono accadere tre cose.
La prima è che vi sia
da cambiare tutta la parte;
la seconda è quella che piace a noi,
ovvero il fai da te.
In questo caso potrebbe essere:
se uno ha le competenze,
e le capacità di farlo,
potrebbe ripararlo, ma non sempre è così.
E infatti, il risultato in molti casi
è diverso da quello che ci aspettiamo.
La terza soluzione è che vi sia
da sostituire tutta la parte.
Ma questo discorso aveva
veramente iniziato ad interessarci,
e quindi abbiamo deciso di compiere
una piccola esplorazione del quotidiano,
ovvero cercare tutti quegli oggetti
che noi utilizziamo quotidianamente
ma che, se si rompono,
sono destinati ad essere gettati via.
Abbiamo trovato un sacco di oggetti
che possono avere lo stesso destino,
e quindi ci siamo chiesti:
ma forse la terza rivoluzione industriale
può iniziare anche da qui;
ovvero, se noi fossimo
in grado di riparare
alcuni degli oggetti
che utilizziamo quotidianamente,
non saremmo forse più ricchi?
Beh, alla fine il pezzo è stato disegnato,
lo abbiamo stampato
e abbiamo riparato l'auto di nostro nonno;
ma questo stesso pezzo oggi,
grazie ad Internet,
potrebbe essere condiviso online,
diffuso in qualsiasi parte del mondo
e un altro utente che si trova
ad affrontare lo stesso esatto problema
potrebbe utilizzarlo
e riparare la sua automobile.
Ma associare la stampa,
o meglio la tecnologia
di stampa tridimensionale,
solo all'idea di poter riparare
un oggetto sarebbe riduttivo;
e infatti, la stampa tridimensionale
è una tecnologia incredibile,
che ha un grandissimo potenziale,
perché permette di materializzare un'idea.
Voi pensate a ciò
che potete avere in mente
e avere qualcosa
che vi permette di realizzarlo,
quindi si tratta di materializzare
un sogno, un'idea, una fantasia.
Questo oggetto che ho in mano
è un oggetto che è stato stampato.
È un giocattolo,
ma in realtà racchiude al suo interno
qualcosa di più complesso.
Infatti la macchina lo ha creato
con una cavità al suo interno vuota,
ed ora vi spiego il suo funzionamento.
Purtroppo non c'è grip
(Applausi)
Questo è soltanto uno
dei possibili oggetti
che si possono stampare
e vediamo alcuni degli oggetti
che sono, a mio avviso,
veramente belli e spettacolari.
Per esempio,
abbiamo il caso di queste cuffie
che sono state interamente stampate,
ad eccezione della parte elettrica;
e quindi questo permette all'utente
di customizzare, cioè personalizzare
le proprie cuffie,
un oggetto che uno può utilizzare
anche quotidianamente.
Ma c'è un altro progetto
molto interessante
che è questo progetto qua:
il progetto di un braccio robotico
interamente stampato.
E il suo creatore
non soltanto ha messo
a disposizione di tutti
il file tridimensionale,
ma anche le conoscenze,
le istruzioni per poterlo assemblare.
Così si è creata una community
intorno a questo progetto
che ha sviluppato, condiviso e creato
nuove parti e nuove possibili applicazioni
di questo braccio.
C'è un altro progetto che stiamo cercando
di portare avanti da un po' di tempo,
ed è un progetto volto alla divulgazione
della tecnologia di stampa tridimensionale
all'interno degli Istituti.
Siamo stati chiamati dall'Istituto Tecnico
di Catanzaro, "O.L.Scalfaro",
quindi da Firenze
siamo partiti per Catanzaro
e siamo andati a presentare
la nostra stampante tridimensionale.
Nel giro di un quarto d'ora
nell'aula c'erano circa 350 studenti
che hanno accerchiato mio fratello
cercando di capire come funzionava.
E quindi ci siamo accorti
di come questa tecnologia
possa invogliare giovani menti,
studenti, ragazzi,
perché può dare la possibilità, appunto,
di poter materializzare un'idea,
di creare qualcosa
che qualcuno ha nella sua testa,
di poterlo toccare con mano.
E infatti nel giro di una settimana,
il prof. Talarico e la sua classe
ha realizzato un progetto da stampare,
che è un progetto di un levitron,
un dispositivo
per la levitazione magnetica.
In una settimana.
Ma non è finita qua.
Infatti siamo stati contattati, anche,
da artigiani, designer,
professionisti, studenti
e alcuni di questi designer
hanno comprato una nostra stampante
e insieme a degli artigiani noti italiani
hanno realizzato una mostra,
in cui hanno utilizzato
la nostra stampante
per poter realizzare oggetti della mostra.
Quando ci hanno chiamato a visionare
quello che avevano fatto,
noi, sì, ci siamo rimasti
proprio di stucco,
perché non credevamo
che si potesse arrivare a stampare,
con un nostro primo prototipo di macchina,
degli oggetti del genere.
È stata veramente
una sorpresa incredibile,
siamo rimasti veramente a bocca aperta,
perché poi gli oggetti
avevano delle parti molto complesse:
portacandele,
addirittura il ramo stesso
di quel tronchetto di albero
è stato interamente stampato.
Incredibile.
Quindi, ricapitolando e per concludere,
siamo stati contattati
da studenti, ingegneri, artigiani
e tutte quelle persone
che sono venute, poi, a trovarci
e che ci chiedevano:
"Ma come si usa la stampante 3D,
che cosa si può fare
con una stampante 3D?"
Noi ancora non abbiamo mai dato
una risposta negativa,
nel senso che non ci è mai
capitato di dire:
"Questo oggetto non si può stampare".
Anche perché, sostanzialmente,
quando qualcuno ti chiede
se si può fare o no,
subito dopo si inizia a stampare.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)